you are a horrible disloyal Unfaithful
liar
[Music]
all right it's uh am I the day
on the Matt wall show yeah we've got a
couple uh submitted
questions from sweet baby gang and then
we're gonna go to Reddit and look at
some from there for him from Trailblazer
says hello Sweet Daddy Matt when I was
uh younger my best friend lived next
door and we hung out all the time as we
got older however he started to act less
Christian and started to feel like a bad
influence I grew up homeschooled in a
Christian family while my friend was
public schooled the older we got the
worse he seemed to behave when we were
eight years old and an adult wasn't in
the room he'd swear like a sailor and
talk trash about my sister whenever I
told him not to talk like that he'd
throw a fit and storm home something
else he'd do was to try and show me
inappropriate Youtube videos with
non-stop cursing and inappropriate jokes
after a while I decided that I was fed
up and I wasn't going to deal with him
anymore I stopped hanging out with him
eight years ago and we've never spoken
since some people thought that it wasn't
Christian like to ditch a friend like
that but I felt that it was the right
thing to do he seemed like a stumbling
block in my relationship with God what
do you think was I overreacting or did I
make the right shoes
uh Well you certainly made the right
choice the people criticizing you do
they think that you owe a lifelong
friendship to this guy like you're
you're Tethered to him forever because
you happened to hang out when you were
kids
like the fact that most people
I don't know how old you currently are
but most people don't remain friends
with the with the people that they knew
early in childhood their whole lives I
mean there are a few examples there are
some friends of mine who I've known
since elementary school but
um it's it's uncommon It generally like
the vast majority let's put it that way
99.9 percent of everybody who you
considered a friend or you know a
friendly acquaintance anyway
um in your elementary school middle
school years even high school you're not
going to continue relationships with
them but part of the reason is that
you know when you're a kid friendships
are first of all it's built a lot of it
is built around just sort of like
there's a certain element of kind of
default to it is it your friends or
something because they live next door or
you went to same school or you went to
the same uh you're in the same class you
kind of bond over it doesn't take much
it doesn't make take much for kids to
bond I mean I I have you know my kids
will they'll go to the playground and um
and I have this conversation all the
time with my with one of my kids they'll
say oh I made a friend at the playground
and then I'll say oh really what was
their name uh I don't know so they make
a friend without even knowing the
person's name because for them friend
just means like you both are going down
the stage you're both are playing on the
same jungle gym or something and you
talk to each other now your friends you
like cherry soda I like Cherry Soda
we'll be best friends which is great you
know it's one of the uh wonderful things
about childhood innocence is that you
can make friends that way but
what that means is that as you grow
older you're going to find that just
because you're friends with this person
doesn't mean that you have any kind of
values in common uh and so it's very
easy to grow apart at that point and as
you get older you know uh you can't be
friends with someone anymore just
because you were both on the same jungle
gym it's like you need you need a little
bit more to maintain that friendship uh
you need some to have some basic values
in common just something there certainly
a shared sense of respect uh is
necessary to begin with so
no you just uh this is just a natural
natural uh
progression of things and nothing to be
concerned about okay from Danielle says
I'm not inviting one of my sisters to my
wedding to make an extremely long story
short I got a temporary restraining
order against my ex-boyfriend because he
was stalking me I.E showing up at my
work following me to the beach breaking
into my house while drunk and coming
into my bedroom at 2 am at the hearing
to make the tro permanent I submitted
evidence of the harassment text messages
including him admitting to coming into
my house eyewitness statements Etc and
he submitted witness statements
attesting to his character as well as a
character assassination of me from my
sister who doesn't know him at all
claiming that I do this to all my
boyfriends I dated her friend for a
period which I ended due to sexual abuse
as well as claiming that I'm a far-right
extremist liar the judge in Liberal
California decided that my sister's
statement outweighed all my evidence and
denied me a permanent restrangler I have
not talked to my sister since then I
have since met my fiance and I'm
planning our wedding am I the
for not inviting my sister to the
wedding well
based on all the information you've
given me and assuming that everything
you've told me here is correct which I
have no reason to think that it isn't
um no you're not the a-hole for not
inviting your sister to the wedding this
is you know I'm sure you realize though
that not inviting a family member
especially an immediate family member to
your wedding is
um
one of the most dramatic statements you
can make about a relationship and the
statement you're making is that the
relationship is over
so there's no coming back from this as
long as you realize that there's no
there's nowhere coming back from it
um maybe like 30 years from now or
something you guys could try to prepare
these uh broken bonds but in the near
term and short term and even you know
the immediate long-term there's there's
no repairing it this is like uh severing
of the relationship
but I would say based on the information
you've given me it's not really you who
severed the relationship she did that
um because
look there there are plenty of cases
where men are unfairly accused of you
know of of being of harassing and all
the rest of it they're being unfairly
accused they're being uh they're being
falsely accused
but in this case if this guy's breaking
into your house
in the middle of the night and coming
into your bedroom I mean this is like
this is criminal activity this is of
course you should feel unsafe around
this person
um this is like this go this to me goes
beyond this goes far beyond harassing
this is like actual breaking and
entering and physical intimidation
inside your own house like really he
should be going to jail for that but if
that's not going to happen then a
restraining order is the least of it and
the fact that she would side with the
other guy
potentially putting your safety at risk
is um
pretty extreme so that's already an
extreme kind of severing of the
relationship that's already happened and
all you're doing I suppose by not
inviting her to the wedding is kind of
uh codifying them the CEO of innovation
refunds at getrefunds.com has been on TV
explaining how they've helped so many
small businesses with the ERC tax refund
they've completed thousands of returns
for different kinds of businesses
including over 700 million dollars for
construction companies and over 200
million dollars in restaurants bars and
hotels Innovation refunds is hundreds of
five-star trust pilot and Google reviews
and it's uh certified with the Better
Business Bureau in just eight minutes
you can easily start the process on
getrefunds.com it could be on your way
to receiving up to twenty six thousand
dollars per employee the ERC tax credit
is not a loan it's a refund of your
already paid taxes designed to let the
business owner direct the refund money
into anything the business needs to grow
it's money that you can use to improve
your business however you see fit so go
to getrefunds.com to start the process
there's no upfront charge they don't get
paid unless you get paid Innovation
refunds has already helped clients claim
over 5 billion dollars in payroll tax
refunds through the ERC and they may be
able to help your business too go to
getrefunds.com or download the app from
the app store today that's
getrefunds.com all right
um then we go to Reddit
my son is 18 and will graduate from high
school in a few months lately he's been
fighting a lot with my wife and I my
wife isn't his biological mother but
she's been his mom since he was three a
week ago they got into a big fight and
my wife got frustrated and yelled at him
that she wasn't his mother since then
he's been completely cold to her and
what he does have to address her he does
so by her first name my wife confiscated
the keys to his car last night but I
gave them back this morning because he
didn't curse at her he just called her
by her name besides I don't want to
drive all the kids to school and then
pick them up my wife is upset and said I
need to support her and talk to him I
think it's pointless he's 18. if he
doesn't want to call her mom we can't
really make him my wife says that I'm
being a lazy that just doesn't
want to have a conversation with him
maybe I am an but I did talk to
him he said he's not going to call her
mom again ever but what am I supposed to
do about it even if we find a way to
force him to he's going to school at a
state so what do we do then just seems
like a pointless battle that will only
create more animosity but maybe that's
just what a lazy Apple would say uh
obviously not the in this case
there are you know we talked about just
a second ago
there are things you can do in a
relationship that severed that
relationship and there's no coming back
from them uh and sometimes it's not even
something you do it can be something
that you say you know it there most of
the time it people in relationships and
family Dynamics you know you could get
angry and say something you regret and
apologize for it and there might be some
hurt feelings there may be uh some
emotional injury that happens but it can
be healed and repaired but there are you
know there are things that you can say
and even though they were just words you
can't come back from them because you've
expressed something that you actually
think and uh the other person is not
going to be able to just forget that you
have revealed this thought
and this would be one of them having
your mother
who's maybe not your biological mother
but is your mom say to you I'm not your
mother
yeah that's one of those things you yeah
he's never gonna forget that ever you'll
never forget that he'll be he'll be 70
years old and still he'll still think
about that uh and it forever changes
that relationship there's no coming back
from it consequences for your actions
you said he's that you're not his mother
now he's gonna call you by your first
name it's gonna forever alter that
relationship
that's consequences report yourself
as the kids would say finally am I the
for criticizing my roommate's
grooming habits harshly hey all I
currently live in a rental department
with my roommate recently we've been
running into some issues because of his
grooming I occasionally notice a funk
coming off of him and a few times it got
bad enough to ask him to take a shower
because it was distracting me and
grossing me out
he apologized and said he had a lessened
sense of smell which made him less
likely to realize he needed a shower
sounded kind of BS to me but he showered
so I didn't think anything of it our
apartment has two full bathrooms in the
hallway and I ordered a bidet for mine
the other day I was installing it and he
happened upon me doing it he uh asked
what it was for and I explained he
chuckled and said you gay guys are
something else I laughed and said it's
less invasive than toilet paper and more
effective he laughed and said yeah but I
don't use that either
what
something clicked in my head and I asked
for clarification apparently he never
wipes why am I reading this
he says he thinks it's gross to rub his
ass with a piece of paper that doesn't
really do anything he said no straight
guy does and it's not a big deal
I uh
okay
so the a-hole here is uh is
the roommate for not
practicing basic human hygiene
is also this other guy for telling us
about this
and it's also my producer McKenna for
sending me this in my VA Hall
submission in the first place
so a lot
there's a lot of a-holes involved
uh in this particular story and we're
just gonna um stop there okay so it goes
on actually goes off like another five
paragraphs this whole if you wanted the
whole Saga of this guy not wiping
himself you can go to Reddit and find it
but uh you're not gonna hear from me all
right
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]